(upbeat music)
- In order to get more creative,
I would encourage young people
to be not afraid of making mistakes.
It's okay to fail while
exploring a new trail of thought.
Know that usually there
is more than one solution
to the problem.
Math is as much about posing
problems as problem solving.
And at that point, creativity is noticing
where there is something
worthwhile investigating.
- As a student in math,
I think it's important to remember
that math isn't just like
random symbols on paper.
Like math can mean something
and it's pretty powerful
that you as a student
can build something that uses math.
Creativity in math isn't just about
being able to pluck numbers from the air
and like, oh yes, I know the solution.
It's about being able to use problems
that help with your daily life.